[Music]
[Laughter]
this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by cash app as you know
cash app is the simplest way to send and
save money and now it's the simplest way
to try and grow your money with cash app
investing this is a true story but one
fire locked himself out of his house and
paid the locksmith with with cash app
$300 just like that
no dunce you know it's yeah that's a
good thing as you left his wallet inside
please to let his phone on them so it's
great use cash app to invest in any
stock for as little as $1 y'all want to
invest cash brokerage services are
provided by cash app investing a
subsidiary of square and member si PC
and as always when you sign up for cash
app and use the promo code Congrats not
only will you instantly receive $10 but
cash app will also now donate $10 to The
Trevor Project an amazing organization
that provides crisis intervention and
suicide prevention services to LGBTQ
across America a download cash app from
the App Store or Google Play Store today
[Music]
episode 157 dude and you know what my
elbow feels tight tight my back was
hurting and it started to get a started
get used to it now I'm at the age of my
babies where it's fine
I'm at the age my babies where my back
is okay uh I remember that age my babies
where I just I'm not gonna get better
you know what I mean I'm just gonna get
used to the pain and that's how my back
is and it's all good finally was getting
used to my back and then much my elbow
tightened up yes dude I have tennis
elbow and I don't even play Tennessee
yes I love that dude I love that for me
I love that for me dude
but anyway it's episode 157 and I'm cool
dude
it's episode 157 and and we did I was in
Irvine last week for shows working out
some new material I've got like 30
minutes a new material from the the
follow-the-leader tour is it poppin yet
my baby is some of its poppin some of it
needs work some of it needs to be thrown
out some of it are little grains of
something that I might work into a
bigger bit and the larger [ __ ] thing
but we'll see who knows
got some bits on different things so
come on out I'm gonna be in Pasadena
California February that's all sold out
saqqaq West Palm Beach Florida March
20th March 21st
Robinson Ville Mississippi for some
reason Horseshoe Casino and hotel
Rohnert Park California April 10th where
is it Las Vegas I got to April 17th and
April 18th Brea California April 30th
through May 3rd and then again I'm going
back May 7th to May 10th the brake
for Nia because let me tell you
something dude they love your boy over
in wherever the [ __ ] Brea is Orange
County is it and then I'm gonna go back
to Las Vegas Nevada because can't get
enough of your boy um Wow
think about for real people who call
themselves your boy and in with will I
can mean it yo what's up is your boy
this your boy pain it's your boy baby
how about how low baby was kind of
popping and then the baby came up and
now little baby's like oh man maybe I
should just be the toddler kya have two
babies in rap so many lilz so many
babies there's also baby isn't there
wasn't that the [ __ ] guy who was the
guy with the teardrop that was the Lil
Wayne baby right I'm too hot too [ __ ]
that part the airs on and I'm not gonna
be sweating and it's all good but I got
that [ __ ] snake chain on dude if
you're watching I have a sneaking but
I'm wearing it on the inside just to let
you know that under it all I'm still a
little bit DMX dude I I don't really
know where to start this podcast to be
honest it's cuz yesterday was the day
that I don't want to start with on too
much of a down downer but like [ __ ] I
found out you know Kobe Bryant died like
a noon yesterday when I was waking up
bright and early at noon and I just
couldn't believe it man I couldn't I
couldn't believe it
it's so [ __ ] weird that he died and
the way he did I gotta say first of all
I cried like all day which I'm not
trying to make it about me but it's so
[ __ ] weird that I cried all day
because I didn't really I don't care
about basketball I don't I don't know
much about Kobe except for you know he
you know he played basketball he's one
of the greatest of all time and and I
just don't I don't know if I I didn't
know I cared that much and then when I
found that out about how he's 41 in a
helicopter crash I don't
I also like I'd never witnessed somebody
a turn the air off it's bugging me I
never noticed about I never noticed how
much like there was so in my life
somebody dying like prematurely or like
even the Robin Williams thing or the
Michael Jackson I was 29 when Michael
Jackson died and Robin Williams when he
died was like six years ago and Robin
Williams was in like in my circle in my
life like like we talked about him all
the time I'm a comedian he was a
comedian I met Robin Williams once and
talked with him for a little bit and
just that was rough but for some reason
the Kobe Bryant thing really [ __ ] hit
me hard like I mean maybe it's because
we're the same age maybe it's because
I'm gonna be a dad or some [ __ ] and his
daughter was in the helicopter and it
just really [ __ ] and it [ __ ] me up
the whole day and I had a show in Irvine
and I wasn't sure if I was gonna be able
to do it the way I do I mean I knew I'd
be able to go on stage and you know I'm
a professional I'll be able to get on
stage and do this [ __ ] but I wasn't sure
if I was gonna you know give be able to
do it a hundred percent now you know I
was able to I got on stage and it was
all good it was fine which I don't know
maybe but I just like was crying for I
four or five times I just like people
would send me videos of what of him and
then an hour before showtime I was like
all right you guys you got to stop man
like I can't I'm gonna be like [ __ ]
upset on stage I just didn't know
I'm surprised how big of a [ __ ] deal
he was to the world like there's nobody
who didn't know who Kobe Bryant was
everybody knows who Kobe Bryant is edit
your [ __ ] seven years old you know
who Kobe Bryant is and he only retired
like three years ago which I didn't even
realize three four years ago it's still
fun it kind of felt like he played
basketball in a way and then the thing
the other night like then take ten hours
before LeBron passed him and in scoring
or whatever it was and and then Kobe was
in the news the night before and then in
the news for being celebrated and then
in the news for being so
in such a tragedy it was just so [ __ ]
awful man I just my heart goes out to
his family and and any I mean dude I was
watching some of the clips like people
were just talking about how like he put
LA he made LA cool again he made LA it's
just I don't realize like you know I
make fun of my opener a lot because he
likes sports and he's [ __ ] 35 and he
like he doesn't pull he's a comedian I'm
like bro just hang it up you know like
stop shooting a basketball at the YMCA
you're [ __ ] 35 have a child you know
Namine work on your jokes the guy's so
competitive it's like he's like you
don't think I can [ __ ] jump further
than you I'm like bro I don't give a
[ __ ] mm 39 you know if you're not
getting paid to do anything with a ball
give it up when you're 24 but my opener
is just like let's go let's go let's
[ __ ] play you don't think I could do
it I'm like I don't not only do I not
even think or not think I don't care but
the point is is basketball when there's
somebody like that that transcends it
it's about an idea it's about it's not
even him which is it is him because you
know he's a real person I don't want to
take that away from him you know you you
you make these people out to be bigger
than they really are and and you think
about how they don't have you know you
don't think of them as like real people
but he was a very real person but like
it becomes about it becomes an idea you
know like Kobe Bryant was an idea and he
was helping women's basketball he you
know the way he was with his daughter
and she wanted to be in the [ __ ] WNBA
and that's just beautiful I mean there's
this clip on I think it's Jimmy Kimmel
talking about how Kobe was just like you
know he's talked about his daughter and
they were saying about how like oh yeah
don't you feel bad that you don't have
any sons you know you need someone to
carry on your legacy and his daughter
will cut him off and be like wow that's
me I'm the legacy and then how he was
like yeah you're right you are the
legacy and that's just so awesome that
he had his daughters [ __ ] back like
that you know I mean look it's hard
enough for [ __ ]
women in in certain ways and just the
fact that he was like an Al and Ally for
his daughters and like it was just
[ __ ] so awesome and it's it's it's
like people need that and now that he
died in such a weird [ __ ] way it's
about the idea it's about the idea that
died too and but yeah but but here's the
thing the idea didn't die because you
still have that idea you know it's it's
it still lives on he's bigger than the
person he was which is [ __ ] man I mean
you know it's more than 99.9% of people
can say and that's a beautiful [ __ ]
thing and it's so tragic the way he died
and it's so tragic the way his you know
how it how it happened but I mean no but
it's tragic however there is also the
idea that lives on and that is just it's
so special men you know I don't get too
serious on this podcast too much because
we like to have a silly goose time and
you know that's my idea that I want to
[ __ ] get out there but when there's a
you know and that's [ __ ] but there's
a real idea behind Kobe Kobe Bryant and
and it's just you know it's really
touching man for a guy like me for a guy
like for a guy like me who doesn't even
[ __ ] watch basketball you know there
were kids out there was nine year olds
out there that were that were like
mourning the the loss of Kobe Bryant and
and 50 year olds out there that were at
the Staples Center that was they were
like you know and and and you know it's
always a shame when somebody like that
dies because they're not able to witness
the love for them and and the and the
togetherness that it you know it brings
us all together afterwards and they're
not able to see it like even my buddy
Brody Stevens who who was a victim of
suicide like he who you know he killed
himself and like to see that guy was
always insecure about people liking him
he thought people didn't like him he
thought you know and he was one of the
funniest guys I've [ __ ] ever met in
my life and I would see him all the time
at the comedy store and he was a friend
of mine and he killed himself and and
and
just the rallying that the the people
the community that the comedians and
then the people outside of people
working mean it just fans that just got
behind the idea of Brody Stephens it's
it's a beautiful
it's a sad but beautiful thing and it's
also a shame that that person can never
see it because he would have loved to
see it and you know I don't know it just
make makes me think you know people say
like grab your loved ones and let them
know you love them and and I suppose
that's very important but my heart goes
out man and that sucks and it's just a
tragedy and hopefully in a few weeks or
months or however a year however long it
takes you to grieve like you can just
start celebrating the idea that Kobe
Bryant was and and that's that you know
I mean I think about Tupac all the time
I know I make jokes about how [ __ ]
you know I got I got this [ __ ] on a loop
here you know and that's not really the
idea that Tupac was behind [ __ ]
someone's [ __ ] but it was the you know
to me to park [ __ ] transcend hip-hop
and transcended his rap music like I
[ __ ] he got me through [ __ ]
certain times in you know as silly as it
is it suburban white kid but like high
school and college and [ __ ] like that
and now whenever some [ __ ] goes down in
the back of my head a little bit [ __ ]
you beat and it helps but you know love
or whatever out there to all the all the
people that are affected by this god I
can't believe how many people I've never
witnessed something even the Michael
Jackson thing I know it was I know
Michael Jackson was probably bigger than
Kobe but I've never seen something like
like this on for a celebrity that died
anyway that's that's the real [ __ ] and
now we'll try to have a silly goose time
I mean I'm not I don't ever promise you
anything it is what it is and we fly by
the seat of our pants my babies and it's
all good but
it's cool it's also cool to me that
someone can like like LeBrons like this
like that someone can [ __ ] be so in
the spotlight I mean and and under a
microscope and just I mean LeBron just
take LeBron like dude where's his
scandal how is LeBron just basically you
know Jesus like I don't want to [ __ ]
get the Catholics mad even though who
cares but like even though who [ __ ]
cares right cuz it doesn't matter right
I don't want to piss off the Catholics
but on one hand I don't want to piss out
the Catholics but on the other hand
cares right couldn't care a rat's ass
you know I'm talking about so why is
LeBron so perfect how come nobody's like
yeah
LeBron [ __ ] got mad and choked me
like bro who is that one Chris Webber
was that the guy who's the guy that
choked the dude that guy wasn't even
[ __ ] LeBron and he was like I'm gonna
choke someone how the [ __ ] do you get
everything LeBron the guy has got the
greatest family great you know he's got
planes and houses he listens to music on
Instagram and makes this face that's his
scandal that's it him turning it up on
Instagram that guy is there a DM out
there that can expose him you know the
guy's [ __ ] unreal and just but my
point is how does he like if someone
[ __ ] with LeBron I feel like Ron will
be like nah that's not worth my time I'm
bigger than that I want to be the bigger
person bro how do you have everything
and also be the bigger person if I had
everything I'm gonna be a small person
if I had [ __ ] more than two pools I'm
getting smaller dude I swear to God if I
get a [ __ ] on like if I if you ever
see me if I ever get a plane if I ever
get a plane I get for real
someone's gonna have to throw me in
because I'm gonna be that's a bit I
swear to God
ladder they'll be like I with other
nighter that ladder down dude are you
kidding me probably put me up to chuck
me in there mm small person now anytime
some [ __ ] goes down
mm patty any time some [ __ ] goes down
somebody could be like you know I'll do
it I'm petty now bro I have to force
myself to not clap back on these trolls
in [ __ ] Twitter dude I have to force
myself not to it when someone talks [ __ ]
to me on Twitter I have to force myself
to turn this [ __ ] down that pops in my
head when somebody is in my Twitter I
swear to god if I get a plane I'm this
parent straight up I'm gonna be so small
people are gonna be like where is he and
I'm gonna be in the room swear to god
I'll be in a cupboard somewhere just
like normal our [ __ ] I'm Chucky swear
to God
when I get a plane I'm Chucky I'm gettin
the overalls and a striped shirt and
just stabbing [ __ ] that talk
[ __ ] to me on Twitter I like how how how
does it happen
look at these [ __ ] that lose
their minds look at Jared Leto hey Jared
Leto we get it you have 19 abs dude you
got abs touching your [ __ ] we get it
they go all the way down we get it Jared
Leto you got abs that go from your
Adam's apple all the way down to the
basic tank also be Patti because you got
a plane when you get a plane how do you
not lose your mind
LeBron he's like nah nah it's all good
I'm an idea that's amazing dude I swear
to God I just
don't understand how you can do that I
mean I know people that are coming up
now that are [ __ ] in the head and
they're not even barely famous they got
tickets to sell they got tickets left to
sell and they're like I was with a buddy
and I'm not even gonna name him because
he's a buddy but he snapped at another
[ __ ] at a fan dude and I was like whoa
bro what about becoming an ideia you
don't even have a house yet and this
guy's like something came up hey what
are you gonna be on Rogen again and the
guy goes the guy says I don't [ __ ]
know whoa
what about LeBron dude you don't even
have a pool that you don't share with
someone you got a pool that you [ __ ]
share with some families because he
gonna complex and it's fine but don't
snap what about being LeBron I know some
of these [ __ ] guys coming up dude and
they're just petty dude and I you know I
try to keep a check on that man but like
I'm not even talking about petty I'm
talking about like dicks I know some
comedians man then they're just jealous
bro and it's like why we're all in this
together the second a person gets bigger
that's in stand-up the second they get
bigger it's better for me
why don't you realize that the more it's
better for all of us the more it's
better for all of us if you go on a tour
with somebody you know if I was gonna go
on a tour with [ __ ] Bobby Lee or
whatever the [ __ ] and we were just now
you know what I don't want to work with
that guy because this happened and that
having out of you Bobby's like I don't
want to work with that guy because his
[ __ ] lips are always wet and he looks
like a bird and I say to Bobby I don't
want to [ __ ] work with Bobby anymore
because he's literally a cartoon and
he's 50 even though he's 12 and I we
talk [ __ ] and then we don't go on tour
together guess what we lose out on each
other's [ __ ] fans and it's not as
good for each other
I mean I got one buddy that's just
trying to that just thinks everyone's
out to get him dude
I'm not going to tell you he's an actor
or comedian but he thinks that everybody
is out to get him dude and he's [ __ ]
it up for himself and I want to talk to
the dude but he's so hard to talk to and
I know that if we talk to it if we talk
to each other he's gonna get defensive
and he's [ __ ] it up for himself dude
because he's about to have it all and I
just want to be like what about planes
dude and quite frankly that's the t
quite frankly that's the tape and I
don't say that kind of [ __ ] cuz you
pretty much have to be like either a
woman or gay to say that's the T but
I'll [ __ ] say it as a heterosexual
male that's the T so I don't know I
don't know man
it's just how are you not rooting for
people how are you not rooting for
people how are you not out there rooting
for people how do you let this [ __ ] and
I'm petty but I'm petty to a point if
somebody talk [ __ ] I talk [ __ ] I told
you [ __ ] and I'm very interested in
but dude that's where it stops how are
you not rooting for people man they're
people that when they do well if
everyone's doing well everyone's doing
well how is that something so hard to
understand especially in the
business dude peeler so jealous man and
you know I guess I get that way
sometimes but I try to [ __ ] think
about it and I came from a good family
so like I had a leg up you know my
parents taught weave him taught me well
and not everybody has taught has had
good parents and not everybody has had a
life of privilege okay but still dude
there's people out there that were
straight-up [ __ ] by their uncle that
run businesses and our good ideas you
know so at the end of the day a rising
tide lifts all boats and I don't know
really what that means but one fire
wrote it and it's true and I do know
what it means a rising tide lifts all
boats that's the truth a rising tide one
fired [ __ ] that's the one thing he
typed on the thing today for some reason
he thinks he's goddamn Confucius and
it's fine dude but it's true a rising
tide lifts all boats dude so get in the
boat here comes the tide I'm breaking
news breaking news manscaped breaking
news this important PSA is brought to
you by manscaped calm this is your pew
oh wow dude this is your pubic service
announcement this is the [ __ ] I'm
reading the manscaped engineering team
this is your pubic a service
announcement dude Wow
the manscaped engineering team spent 18
months perfecting the greatest ball hair
trimmer ever created and just released
the new and improved lawn mower 3.0
the third-generation trimmer feature is
a cutting edge ceramic blade to prevent
manscaping accidents millions of balls
are about to be knick free thanks to man
escapes advanced skin safe technology at
all a geology ology I've been talking
about manscape for a while now and you
know what manscape products made
personal grooming something I actually
care about alright if you use the
lawnmower 2.0 it's an easy transition
because it's the same replacement blade
with a new and improved skin safe
technology and I tell you this is
premium okay and I mean Premium the
battery will last up to 90 minutes so
you can take a longer shave you got big
balls no prob okay
the circumference of your balls the if
it's like a melon no problem in 'its for
one battery they've upgraded to 7000 RPM
motor with a cool with quiet stroke
technology it's a stroke if you're
listening to me speak right now you're
one of the first people to hear about
this life-changing product and I want
you to experience it firsthand for
yourself
trim that junk yours get 20% off free
shipping again for 20% off plus free
shipping with code Congrats at manscape
calm your balls will thank you get 20%
off and free shipping with the code
congrats at manscaped comm that's 20%
off with Free Shipping at manscaped calm
and use code Congrats honey book you've
done it your creative passion is now
your full-time job congratulations
but maybe you wish someone would have
told you how much time drafting
proposals creating contracts and chasing
down payments would take the good news
is that honey book can help with all
those tedious admin tasks so you can get
back to doing what you love that's the
goal right you don't have to do the
tedious stuff so honey book is an online
business management tool that organizes
your client communications bookings
contracts and invoices all in one place
it's perfect for freelancers
entrepreneurs or small business owners
that want to consolidate services they
already use like QuickBooks Google suite
excel and mail
jimp they also have East signatures and
built-in automation to save your time
and get you paid faster and right now
honey book is offering our listeners 50%
off when you visit try honey book.com
slash Congrats payment is flexible and
this promotion applies whether you pay
monthly or annually t ry h o NE y bo
ok.com / Congrats go to try honey
book.com / congrats for 50% off your
first year that's try honey book.com
slash Congrats man do you did you guys
see the the lit this is so this is as
ridiculous as this is like peak 2020 I
kind of amyl people say that but this is
the [ __ ] truth
newscaster bring it when the newscaster
said the LA Lakers remember when she
said that did you guys see this I mean
it went viral the other day but the lady
basically was it's talking about Kobe
Bryant wait no which don't Michael Bryan
yeah she was and it was the LA Lakers
and she was gonna say Knicks and she
said LA makers and it did not sound like
makers and also nakos even sounds bad
so she said it and and it was so and it
was so like what the [ __ ] because she
said it quick and there were people that
actually thought that it was an outrage
that she said the n-word which is
absolutely [ __ ] insane to me like
imagine being so racist and insane but
also you were able to climb the ladder
at as a newscaster to get to the point
where you're like no matter what here it
goes
this is the moment I've been waiting for
when one of the most beloved athletes of
all time dies prematurely I've got it
I've got my chance on the worldwide
stage
to slip in the n-word and let everybody
know like there are people that actually
think she said that and she's racist
which is so [ __ ] insane
she obviously made a [ __ ] goof but
people are going to want people are
trying to cancel this lady the fact that
this lady even has to apologize for na
for saying nay kurz is ludicrous but
here it is and it does sound bad I mean
and said it dude took a break and said
the n-word took a break took a breath
and was just like let her rip my babies
I'm racist and I can't help it anymore
you know what [ __ ] it here we go I know
I know it's taboo but gotta say it also
the worst time you know it couldn't have
been a worse time literally literally
couldn't be in a worse time one of the
most famous beloved black people of all
time died and she couldn't have said it
at a worse time
died fresh one hour before that and she
had to slip in the n-word hilarious
anyway she obviously didn't [ __ ] do
that so lay off her case it was a
mistake she meant to say [ __ ] nix I
think she said which is crazy as it is
because Nix have nothing to do with it
but that's what her explain explanation
was I guess she kind of does kind of owe
an explanation because it really does
sound like the N word still a there be
great if she just said
[ __ ] the like a gay slur like the one
that began with F and we were like I'm
so sorry I meant to say fire hydrant and
maggots like wait what that really I
just hate gays but that's just I just
hate gays I couldn't help it couldn't
help it um I I just think it's how about
[ __ ] Ari Shaffir dude this guy is a
troll it's the weirdest thing about Ari
man let me play this or you want to
bring it up it's the weirdest thing
about Ari it's like I know Ari and he's
always been the [ __ ] nicest guy to me
like just all like I don't judge people
I try not to judge people unless like
until I've met them and the guys like
legitimately one of the nicest guy he's
so nice every now and then he Texas I
haven't talked him in maybe over a year
but like every now and then he texts me
and he's also done no [ __ ] like he
he texted me once that comics weren't
getting paid enough and he was like I'm
trying to sign this position petition
for comics to get paid and I was like
that's really sweet
and then he [ __ ] dosed Bert Kreischer
it with his family and and did this [ __ ]
and it's just so but he just I
understand he's a troll but he wrote
Kobe Bryant died 20 years too late today
he got away with rape because all
Hollywood rule Ibrahim adiy enjoy
rooting for Lakers but play the [ __ ] in
the video that Rappaport tweeted it if
you look on his and it's also probably
all over YouTube but but yeah like he
just did this thing and here's the thing
here's the weird thing about let me let
me actually play it and then and then
I'll get to it I mean all day
Rappaport's been [ __ ] it was such a
sports fan I mean couldn't be posting
more Kobe [ __ ] I love Michael Rapaport
he's such a [ __ ] nice dude but no
it's not understand on Instagram he took
it down no so I get pissed right because
one fire is taking too long and I could
have found it already but I get pissed
so he linked it up to put it on his
computer and play the audio on his
computer but no I
pissed off because the first thing you
do when you pipe in a literally comes up
Ari Shaffir Kobe video and he just went
too far and put Ari Shaffir and then
clicked on only only Ari Shaffir and
that's when I get pissed off now it's
fine because I'm trying to be an idea
and I don't want to be petty but here it
is play it pain in the world
it's always a bunch of terrible stories
every once in a while there's a good
story good story comes out
the guy who got away with rape got his
today
Hopi Bryan is I'm gone I'm here at
Charlotte the Homewood team that
originally drafted him maybe wouldn't
break that chick in Denver if he'd been
maybe it stayed in Charlotte with the
Hornets anyway is that it um it's so
weird that he did that I know he's a
troll and here's other thing too people
are like you know it's calm some people
who are defending him are like it's
comedy it's comedy which yeah and
they're like well where's the joke and I
think look re is playing a character
that and and he obviously gets off on
trolling people like it's what he wants
and okay and it's insane to me like it's
[ __ ] utterly insane that he wants
people to [ __ ] hate him like he's a
heel I get it okay if this was the WWF
he would be [ __ ] Hollywood Hogan or
whatever but bro people are not gonna
know you're joking
and also there's not really a joke in
there he's just kind of like trying to
get people eight people on and also
here's the other thing dude you're gonna
get your ass kicked
like you're a comedian people always
know where you are this when they my jaw
dropped when he did this and I guess the
whole idea is he wants people to talk
about it and [ __ ] like that but [ __ ] man
I mean it's bad to do that it's
just I don't know man and the other
thing too is like he he's like Jojo like
a lot of you'll know he is from Joe
Rogan and so people are tagging Joe
Rogan come get your boy like you got to
think about like that dude like oh god I
don't understand when people like
wannabe so I don't understand I don't
even know I don't even get it like I
just don't get how it isn't the idea as
a community to put butts in seats like
people are just gonna boycott you I
guess he's trying to find the [ __ ]
real dregs of the earth that are just
like me and [ __ ] yeah that's a weird
fanbase though man I mean people even
comedians are so many cuz that's the
thing it's kind of bad for comedy to do
[ __ ] like that because people are like
oh well he's gonna here we go hide them
behind [ __ ] like it's a joke
and you're gonna just say it's a joke
right and comedians just can say
anything without repercussions and it's
like yeah well we're supposed to be able
to but also make it funnier than that
dude make it a little bit I don't know
wink or something so you don't get
killed it's a it's a weird thing for me
to see do it cuz like I said our has
always been super nice to me and to see
him just do that is just so [ __ ]
weird what a lunatic what a lunatic dude
I always think it's weird this is not
you know I don't know if Ari does this
or not I'm talking about some house now
but like I was think it's weird that
when like somebody dies or whatever the
[ __ ] something happens kid gets molested
it gets exposed like comedians just
raced to Twitter and like are like I let
me come up with the best joke so it'll
pop off and it's just like dude give it
time man or like what about the families
I guess you know I honestly felt weird
posting I haven't posted since Kobe died
because I felt weird
because I don't really post about
serious [ __ ] you know I've kind of made
it a point to not post about serious
[ __ ] because I don't you know it's
comedy I want to do comedy mostly the
95% of the time um I probably owe more
than 95% of the time but so serious
posts always kind of make me feel weird
to do as a comedian and I'm not saying I
never do it or I sure you should never
do it if you are a comedian but um [ __ ]
I'd totally lost my train of thought but
yeah I just I just feel like it's weird
to even post about anything besides Kobe
right now because everybody knows about
it and it would just be weird to be like
here's a funny video I made uh I guess
out of respect I don't know morning I
don't know uh not sure really I don't
know what to say about that or anything
man that was [ __ ] crazy and here's
the other thing too like people are like
I want to [ __ ] him up I want to [ __ ]
beat the [ __ ] out of him that's not the
answer either I mean I know there's a
bit that I don't want to ruin the bit
but what's his name Chris de Stefano
mate was doing this funny bit about how
very generally like people people I love
Chris de Stefano man love this dude and
it was he was talking about how people
need to get people on Twitter say
anything because they're behind the
keyboard and they need to get punched in
the mouth though like you need to get
punched in the mouth people like that
need to get punch about and that's a
reason why they're behind of keyboards
because they need to get punched in the
mouth whatever it's [ __ ] hilarious
obviously what I said wasn't just funny
because it's not my bit and I just
[ __ ] was explaining it but and I
don't want to say the funny part because
it's his material you should go see him
but he you know if punched in the mouth
is one thing but like people are like
tweeting addresses their tweet like that
[ __ ] is [ __ ] crazy bro these people
need to get get check
punched in the mouth is one thing but do
it don't incite a [ __ ] mob that is
insane
all right Liz your address this is a
person's address this is everyone's
address go ahead like that's I don't
know I don't think that's the answer man
I don't think that's the answer I know
some people have done some bad [ __ ] but
you got to let the [ __ ] whatever it
is the authorities or the people that
are the powers that be I don't know man
all right I got to do these [ __ ] ads
here here we go kaptara
if you work for a small business or have
a side gig which is so many people out
there you probably need to find software
okay but you also have other things to
do all right like maybe you got a family
or your hobbies or whatever like work
can be hard you've got things you'd
rather be doing well you can cut to the
chase job wise with kaptara
this is the website that millions of
people use monthly to find software for
their teams or business so you can have
more time to do the things you want to
do they simplify the software search
into a few few steps
it starts with using their free
resources and guides to pinpoint the
problem and identify the software
features you need then you can filter
options to find the right software for
your industry they have over 700
specific categories of software I was
just on the website and I'd look I just
typed in church and you can they have
like so many software software programs
that they narrow out that they can be
like alright this is what you use if you
want to if you need apps for church or
help for for you know your website or
whatever that whatever the hell it is
it's it's amazing and then you can
compare them and be like okay well this
is the one I need I mean it's just it
saves you so much time it was actually
quite impressive you can compare them
side-by-side
save your side-by-side saviors to the
favourites to a shortlist with free
in-depth software guides and tools plus
over 1 million reviews from real users
kaptara will give you access to anything
you need to know before you buy so you
can spend less time trying to find
software and more time
doing what you love and cutting your
work time drastically visit kaptara comm
/ congrats for free today to find the
software tools you need for your
business kaptara comm / Congrats kaptara
that's CA p ter are a.com slash Congrats
capt erra kaptara
software selection simplified
congratulations is brought to you by
cash app the official app of the log
cabin yeah so anyway did I get a say men
you babies are amazing the listeners and
all that stuff because because I want to
show you guys here we go if you go to
the app that the what do you call it the
podcast app on Apple and you go to
reviews congratulations
somebody alerted me this alerted me to
this on Twitter by the way I stopped
checking Twitter a lot because that's
when New Year's resolution so I don't
let you [ __ ] heathens get to me too
much because I [ __ ] trying not to you
know too much but you know why does it
say unconscience with Chris D'Elia hosts
are [ __ ] me and dave bautista that's
weird man Dave Bautista has never been
on this show and also doesn't host the
show but I will tell you one thing don't
fix it leave it
what the [ __ ] put that there what if
dave bautista did it he's like well I
just really like and want to be
considered part of it how about this how
many reviews 20,000 seventy-four reviews
and ratings we have a 5 point 5 out of 5
my babies
you killed it that's so awesome and
means so much to me that you guys helped
loving it loving it loving it loving it
it's crazy how many reviews we have go
out there and review more let's try to
get it to 21,000 now for next week let's
see what Dateline has sometimes I fall
asleep today line and sometimes I try to
fall asleep to end a line cuz of like
Leicester holds voice or Keith Morrison
or the guy that sounds like this I don't
know who that is you know what I mean
Laura was a Laura was a beautiful young
girl that had a family and it was
everything to her and she loved cars but
she got ran over by one of her cars did
she do it herself or was it her jealous
boyfriend who is that guy that's Josh is
that judge mekka weights no no that's
not Josh mecha wits is it Dennis Murphy
it's gotta be Dennis Murphy Dennis
Murphy nobody looks like they get food
on their [ __ ] shirt more than Dennis
Murphy he looks like he has [ __ ] he
he would eat like even [ __ ] that you
don't get places here play play it's
gotta be him hey guys it's Dennis Murphy
from the day line [ __ ] I just wanted to
tell you we're finishing up some stories
here in southern Illinois and we were
just look like you get Egyptian Hills
want to give him a shout-out you guys
are lucky to be living in such a pretty
part of the country god I want to know
that guy go go to one of his things
though where he's like in a small remote
area on a lake he's it always sounds
like he's figuring out what he's saying
is he's on a lake with a boat sam-i-am
boy you're like imagine you had him as a
[ __ ] dad and he read green eggs and
ham to you bro you'd just be hey will
you read green eggs and ham and he'd be
like green eggs and ham and you'd be
like but he'd be into it he'd keep
reading because he'd love it
I'm on a boat i'm on a boat I'm on my
throat Ryan Widmer breaks not this
[ __ ] [ __ ] man one fire till the day
Grier it's no holds barred no lawyers
present no money exchanged hands Ryan
wanted to tell a story he wanted to tell
the Dateline so I think the greater sin
when they hear the name Ryan Widmer or
the bathtub case they start to gag but I
think this really is must-see viewing
for people that have followed this for
so long
he tells a story and Karen I think
sometimes I got it out turn it off I
can't do it I got it right here dude
it's gonna be a commercial no I'm gonna
be pissed
can't wait for this to be a commercial
here we go when the phone rang she
thought I'm gonna do SEC phone call from
her son home sick college student about
the six hour drive away but it wasn't it
was the police saying that he was
missing a few days later they found his
frozen body out in the woods making it
up making it up and then fish so good at
his job he'll be like I got it I got it
and then he does it and making it up and
but gets it right still makes it up her
frozen body was in the woods and purrs
like how the [ __ ] did he read the thing
they're like no and he's like I've been
around long enough I know how I know how
people die all you have to do is tell me
their name it was David seltzer
oh he froze in a lake he froze in his
boat and his wife did it the greatest
cop of all time jessica's he's a
voiceover a [ __ ] um yeah so well I go
to try to sleep the dateline but then it
gets so interesting like I was listening
to this one called the intruder and dude
a line it's so good how it makes it seem
like you're like oh well [ __ ] dude
his family died [ __ ] man this guy had it
rough what he's crying and the phone
calls like I don't know and then [ __ ]
20 minutes in you're like oh he did it
how did they make me on his side and
then just switch me over and realize
that he did it he completely did it um
anyway I got to get a [ __ ] turtleneck
that's the thing
you guys better believe I'm getting it
or like I'm not [ __ ] around - I'm
getting a turtle egg I gotta get one
before [ __ ] it gets warm cuz I gotta
wear this turtleneck cuz dude I'm gonna
look so goddamn sexy in a turtleneck
it's unreal dude I swear to God you know
what as a matter of fact yeah this week
I'm getting a turtleneck dude
this week I'm getting a turtleneck and
all you [ __ ] haters that think
I won't can go kiss my [ __ ] ass dude
I'm getting a turtleneck and it's gonna
come up to my [ __ ] jaw and
bro it's gonna make my [ __ ]
mandibular pop out so hard I swear to
god you know what I'm gonna do I'm
getting a turtleneck but I also guess I
got to get tabbles because there's gonna
be chicks around and I don't want their
[ __ ] [ __ ] sweating the holes so
much that they slip and fall and break
their ankles cuz then I got a lawsuit
dude I'm gonna get her a turtleneck and
then I'm gonna get a bag of [ __ ] big
towels and just pass them out when I see
chicks and she'll be like why oh I got
it
why are you and then see me about my
[ __ ] [ __ ] poppin cuz also I trim my
beard to make it look like bro when I do
a four or a five on the trimmer and my
jawline it's like people are like yo did
someone draw that so I got now a
turtleneck with a four or five trim and
I'm gonna be walking around town like
it's legal dude I've got a back I'm
gonna get two bags I'm gonna get a
backpack and two [ __ ] big IKEA bags
of of tabbles and whenever I see a chick
especially in a skirt I gotta pass out a
towel because I don't want her to break
her ankles I don't want to do I don't
want to [ __ ] I don't want her to slam
her tailbone on the [ __ ] conk I don't
want that excuse me ma'am sorry but I've
got a turtleneck on if I wear a
turtleneck they'll let me in anywhere
just so you know just so you know
they'll let me in anywhere dude that's
how [ __ ] sexy are look oh [ __ ] and
then this oops
oopsie Daisy can you hear it on audio
oopsie Daisy the heavy sneak chain comes
out halfway through the night I gotta go
get more towels
you understand me dude I swear to god
man put a turtleneck on my body see what
happens put a turtleneck on my [ __ ]
torso and see what happens
dude me put it on like this and then
[ __ ] fold in and over whoops me
folding it over like that putting it on
and then meet put the puss on like this
putting it on like this and me folding
overs on the guitar kicks me taking the
[ __ ] cuz it's not mock and just
and then all of a sudden passing out
towels do it there you go there you go
and then chicks whoa and because I can't
it's a shame too because I can't get get
towels out fast enough because when I'm
in crowded places girls are like what
the [ __ ] and they fall and they fall
casual they become you know they become
casualties to my [ __ ] turtleneck game
casualties to a turtleneck game that's
what they become and it's sad too man
but hopefully they were an idea
it's sad as [ __ ] I'm sorry sweetheart I
tried to get over here as quickly as I
could to get you a towel I know because
I've got a turtleneck on it was really
[ __ ] irresponsible and dangerous of
me but I and I also have a [ __ ] four
or five on my trimmed beard but it's
really [ __ ] sad here's an extra towel
before you get up put it down I don't
want you slipping and falling because
your [ __ ] gets so wet because I've got
a [ __ ] turtleneck on and then run
hustle away with my [ __ ] IKEA bags
just making this a noisy running away
with my two big IKEA bags and a [ __ ]
turtleneck on with a heavy chain out
just slapping against my chest dude god
how sexy can you goddamn be I also got a
bat I [ __ ] I also got a backwards hat
I don't call it I had I call it a
backwards hat
I got a backwards hat I got a [ __ ]
hat in Florida once and I wore it and it
was so sexy and everyone was like
goddamn you so [ __ ] what's going on
you'd do things to me in this hat I had
to get some [ __ ] towels and then I
left I had on the plane and then a few
months went by I'm worn the hat and then
I [ __ ] was in Irvine today and I got
an LA hat so I'm about to start
man it's too bad a turtleneck with a
[ __ ] hat doesn't look good cuz it
doesn't because if it did they would
call me population control
that's legit what they would call me
because people would be slipping and
falling and breaking their goddamn neck
anyway dude I don't mean to brag but I'm
[ __ ] extremely sexy in a turtleneck
and a heavy chain peeking out and then
also just with [ __ ] I would have cool
pants on too inland then then he has a
turtleneck and also a heavy snake chain
that sometimes he takes
out halfway through the night but also
he's got too heavy
IKEA bags with dozens of towels in them
just in case women get so wet while
looking at him noticing his his five his
number five razor shaped beard and and
gets so wet and then the wet goes down
their legs if they're wearing a skirt
and then they slip and hurt their
tailbone that's when the Lea would come
up and hand them a towel out of his IKEA
bag and hope for the best as he ran away
giving out towels to women that saw him
Wow well we started with some real
poignant [ __ ] on this podcast and then
turned into some absolute ridiculous but
I told you to silly goose time dude
it's a [ __ ] silly goose time dude
it's a [ __ ] silly goose time man and
life [ __ ] rips man just remember even
when celebrities die and ideas [ __ ]
fade life rips you've got to remember
that [ __ ] do it well I've continues to
rip and it continues to rip and it
continues to rip and it continues to rip
dude I'm a preacher so go get your life
rips merch and the ohm trimming a dollar
do it and it does it whatever bro I
don't or don't get one man it's an idea
um my buddy knows my schedule you have
coffee bean I have that shirt in my car
and I'm headed there and then he writes
me one at 149 and then at 152 well holy
[ __ ] it's closed forever that's crazy
and then he writes I think maybe you're
recording socia he knows it he knows my
business that's awesome dude this is the
one dude one fire just sent me this one
this [ __ ] turtleneck dude you know
what I need to do wow that's a good one
Saint Laurent cable roll neck knit oh
it's only 365 oh wow it's sold out great
yes dude I saw [ __ ] turtleneck the
other day at a place and it was so
poppin and it was $3,000 and I was like
are you kidding me sure bags but you're
kidding me I was like sir of course bank
account splode n' but you kidding me I
was like sure got open
the windows to my house so the cash can
breathe but can me
I was like sure I've got stacks and if I
lay down looks like I've got three [ __ ]
in my pants but still
hey kidding me come on dude
it was 3k and I'm like pass but also
guess what wish I got it cuz now did
Leon's no [ __ ] deadly aren't dude I'm
getting a black turtleneck and y'all
could go [ __ ] yourself for real and put
that on my tombstone when I die for real
and I know someone's gonna Photoshop
this [ __ ] whatever do it but when I die
put this on my tombstone I'm getting a
black turtleneck and y'all can go [ __ ]
yourself for real I'm serious
oh I'll do it I can't wait to get it
I'll wear shorts with it you [ __ ] umm
yeah so I'm gonna get a [ __ ] look at
these [ __ ] turtlenecks bro you know
what I need to do I need to be one of
those [ __ ] hookers on Instagram and
be like here's my here's my gift list
and just have one thing on it a [ __ ]
dope 3k turtleneck and some rich [ __ ]
either old housewife lady or some old
fan is gonna get me one dude and then
send it to my P o box and I'll rock that
[ __ ] dude I need to get one of those
hooker things when models have that
[ __ ] thing here's my gift list my LIF
my gift list you're a [ __ ] a
straight-up hooker do it just blow dicks
how about that if you look at what's on
it a bag oh yeah well I don't why do
girls love to keep things in things mr.
Porter they got [ __ ] turtlenecks who's
that
I don't know but turtlenecks are amazing
the authority seemed to write off that
death to youthful indiscretion aching it
uh but still getting it ooh a brown
turtleneck looks nice Ralph Lauren
Ralph Lauren rough lung huh i'ma make it
more rough Lauren purple label need it
Wow I'm gonna be the only [ __ ]
in summer wearing a paternal neck I
don't
those puffy ones God you look like a
[ __ ] when you were those puffy ones the
puffy necks wow you look like a [ __ ]
like what is this 1996 in your Lance
Bass oh wow look at this one logo and
now look at this one Jesus Christ like a
Bill Cosby
I know warm day um can't wait to get a
turn light you [ __ ] you're not
gonna know what hit ya that's how you
know I'll know that chicks are feeling
me with my turtleneck but don't be like
hey pass out it to imma bring little
towels around for real like I'm gonna do
that I'm gonna straight-up do that at
the Laugh Factory one night maybe
Wednesday night yeah that's what I'm
gonna do
all right that's it Twitter questions
now [ __ ] it should we wrap would you
let's look at a Twitter question or two
oh we should do [ __ ] we got to do it
you know we're gonna do next time
Instagram most [ __ ] up Instagram post
of the week we got to start doing that
again that was fun and people are
dummies [ __ ]
what about these Australian fires but
still showing me these did their titties
and [ __ ] okay
Congrats bye oh did deserve it scale
look at this lady Wow dude leave this
girl she's going like [ __ ] 12 miles
an hour in a target with an ax on a bike
and she tried to take a hard turn
she obviously hadn't ridden a bike in
years and I'm FAL what's the deserve it
scale Wow deserve scales I don't know at
a 10 bro I mean you're going 12 miles an
hour on a [ __ ] mountain bike ena oh
no that's not even a mountain bike it's
a it's a one of those basket bikes and
just [ __ ] crashing near the
Tupperware you know with a jean jacket
on don't ride a bike with a jean jacket
on Wow
here we go oh here we go my brother and
I have this argument all the time is it
is it CUDA to not do something that you
like because other people say you
shouldn't for example liking a shirt
certain show or reading comics or things
like that glue
argument good argument I think people I
think it's more about the hive mind like
people don't think for themselves being
a CUDA distilled that's a term if you're
if you're new to the congratulations
podcast you're a CUDA it comes from
being a barracuda
barracudas just see shiny objects and
gravitate towards them
you CUDA right like Coachella is CUDA
because maybe you don't even like the
band's plane but you're like gotta go
cuz everyone else is going right so like
a comic or like certain show watching it
it just just watching it isn't CUDA like
if you're at home and you're like let me
see what this [ __ ] watchman is all
about because people are talking about
it
that's not CUDA but if you don't get it
and you're like I still got to watch it
and then somebody talks about how good
it is and you don't think it's good and
you're like oh no yeah it's great it
code but just doing it you know things
become popular and and they're popular
for a reason but you know it's always a
fine line man and we all have a little
bit of CUDA in us and I always say this
you know you have to have a little bit
of CUDA it's cuz if you don't you're
dead you're not [ __ ] you're a cold
body but yeah so I can't really answer
that question be harder but ya know I
know the answer is no it's not CUDA just
to do something that other people like
because you have to learn what you like
anyway anyway that's good that's good
what's it what we're done does over an
hour we're good
you guys are great come to see me in
Brea I got two weekends there it's gonna
sell out it's a big club but you got to
get your tickets now I'm gonna be in
Brea that's gonna be fun I'm working out
this new material I got like 30 minutes
of new material by that time I'll have
more than that I'm trying to eke out
this follow-the-leader tour you know how
many cities I did on [ __ ] the
follow-the-leader tour as a matter of
fact here's the deal here's what I'm
gonna do right now i I have I played a
lot of cities I the follow-the-leader
tour follow-the-leader tour so drunk but
if you can guess how many cities I
played and tweet it to me or DM it to me
whatever I don't really see many diems
but if you tweet it to me and you get it
right I'll give you two free tickets to
my show next time
the first person who gets it I'm not
gonna forgive it if everyone gets it I'm
gonna be you know I gotta make these
bags but the first person that guesses
how many cities I did on the
follow-the-leader tour my agent just
told me the first person that gets it
I'll give you two of free I'll get two
free tickets and I will meet you when I
come to your city so that's the
competition so just guess and that's and
then and then that's cool and then
that's a competition that will do a
giveaway or whatever the [ __ ] and text
me actually no you know what that's what
we're gonna do
you're not gonna tweet it you're gonna
text it to me I'm gonna check my texting
my community texts and the first person
to text me how many cities correctly how
many cities I did on the
follow-the-leader tour I'm gonna give
you two four tickets at a meet-and-greet
when I come to your city next time my
text text me at eight one eight two
three nine seven oh eight seven that's
eight one eight two three nine seventy
eighty seven text me the first person
text me the amount of cities that I
played on followed leader tour gets two
free tickets and a meet-and-greet and
that's it
so yeah we're life rips hoodies I think
they're all sold out [ __ ] again but
I'll try to restock them when I can you
guys I mean you guys we added the black
ones now they're so dope I didn't even
know people would walk the black ones
but now they're selling more you more
than tie-dyed ones you guys love you
guys remember life rips and keeping it
real keeping it real keep it real and
try to be positive man just be positive
you guys I guess
the guys some of you somebody guys
probably pieces of [ __ ] but uh see you
soon
see in West Palm Beach you know all the
places
[Music]